three years ago john cena jiki fled
nigeria because his political views made
him a target for violence
he's applied for political asylum in
germany but until an approval is issued
he could always be deported
soccer is a good distraction while he
waits to find out if he'll be allowed to
remain
this football have made them like every
time we come to training they come out
with the time they are here playing
football talking with other people they
have much relief they have they think
they think away all the problems they
forget about all the problems
in that particular time they are playing
at the barbers bag football club in
potsdam refugees don't just have the
chance to kick it around
they founded their very own team
welcome united 03.
the multinational squad isn't just
supported by the club
its fans have paid for some uniforms
we cook and eat with the refugees too
we've always done things together with
them
for years now this has been completely
normal for us in bubble's back and
setting up the team just seemed like the
next logical step
next season welcome united will be
playing in a local league
like all newcomers they'll start at the
bottom of the table but that's where the
problems start
the international football association
fifa requires every player to have a
player pass
the german football association the dfb
has to implement the regulation
in the case of welcome united refugee
players the dfb must ask in their home
countries if they're already registered
with clubs there
the process takes about two or three
months the players don't always
understand why it takes so long when a
german or another player from an eu
country joins the team they can get out
on the pitch and play inside of two
weeks
sex is it's five social worker karoline
gaffon has often referred soccer playing
asylum seekers to clubs
and every time it's a bureaucratic can
of worms
up to a certain league you can let them
just do without it countries like
somalia afghanistan and syria have
better things to do than answer these
inquiries in fact the authorities who
would issue them likely don't even exist
anymore
at the baba's back football club's
office they're critical of this practice
making an inquiry in libya for example
when someone's come here for political
reasons i'll tell you from the get-go
there's no point in even trying it just
wastes time and it's got to stop
the state of brandenburg soccer
association is responsible for welcome
united 03
they admit here that home countries
never respond to the inquiries
but they still defend fifa strict
regulations
it could be that players are applying
under fraudulent conditions
or they could already have contracts or
have been banned these things have to be
checked that's why fifa's given
associations a 30-day deadline for
responding
many asylum seekers that play soccer in
their free time have actually waited
much longer
they feel persecuted by an uptight
german system addicted to following
rules
and to add insult to injury if you want
to play for points in a german league
you need even more documents
think it is not allowed anywhere in
deutschland for someone who doesn't have
a permanent residence to to play
actually play with them
in their football club
the german football association is loud
about its commitment to integration in
its ads like this one showing the
parents of the world cup winning german
national team
and it's true that its players come from
many cultures and
national
backgrounds
dfb
mass integration but more integration at
this level of the sport fans in
babelsbeck are skeptical about that they
think the german football association
could do far more
the political and social commitment that
the dfb likes to brag about is not
really as rooted as it needs to be in
the behavior of the people who work for
it
it always takes pressure from the
outside to get the dfb to recognize
problems and act accordingly instead of
stepping up on their own initiative and
supporting measures and ideas that
really would promote more integration in
real life
brandenburg soccer club is now promising
that none of the players on welcome
united will have to wait long for their
documents
in the coming season they'll play for
points
or at least the ones who haven't been
deported yet will